افادت ديعو احرونوت بوجود تقديرات لدى
وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه تفيد بان عدد
الجنود المصابين
باعقبه ان قسم اعاده تاهيل الجنود بوزاره
الدفاع تعامل مع
3400 جندي صنفوا معاقين في الجيش منذ
السابع من
اكتوبر معنا من غلاف غزه مراسله الجزيره
نجوان سمري نجوان ما جديد التطورات
العسكريه
لديك نعم اولا صباح هذا اليوم دوت صافرات
الانذار في منطقه ناح العوز في غلاف غزه
وهذا ايضا تكرر يوم امس و منذ صباح هذا ال
اليوم رصدنا المواقع الشماليه في قطاع غزه
كانت هناك بعض ال التفجيرات التي سمعت او
سمع دويها من المناطق التي تواجدنا بها
وهي عمليات تفجير واسعه يقوم بها الجيش
الاسرائيلي تحديدا سلاح الهندسه لعدد من
المنازل والمباني مما لم يتدمر عمليا على
مقربه من السياج الحدودي خلال عمليات
القصف الجوي والبري هنا في المناطق
الشرقيه لقطاع غزه ايه باستطاعتنا بطبيعه
الحال ان نرصد حجم الدمار في هذه الاحياء
تحديدا منطقه الشجاعيه لكن الى الشمال
منها في حيي الدرج والتفاح ما زالت هناك
عمليات للجيش الاسرائيلي وفقا لبياناته
الاخيره وهناك توقعات لدى قاده الجيش بان
تنتهي هذه العمليات في الاحياء الشماليه
لمدينه غزه مطلع او خلال الاسبوع ال
المقبل ايه ليكون بذلك قد اتم وفقا
لتصريحاته السيطره الكليه على المناطق
الشماليه في قطاع غزه كما تسمعون معنا هذا
قصف مدفعي متواصل ايضا لكنه ي يستهدف
بالاساس منذ نحو الساعه مناطق المناطق
الوسطى في قطاع غزه المخيمات مخيم البريج
و ربما يستطيع الزميل المصور ان يظهر هذه
المناطق نرى منها اثار القصف واعمده
الدخان كذلك منطقه جحر الديك تحديدا هذه
المنطقه طيله الوقت تتعرض لقصف متواصل
لاسما الاحياء التي تقع الى الغرب منها اي
كال مغراق ولكن بالاساس مخيمات الوسط
نستطيع ان نرصد من هنا قصف عنيف يستهدف
هذه المواقع سواء كان البريج ولكن ايضا
المخيمات الاخرى النصيرات والمغازي الى
الجنوب وك كذلك منطقه الزوايده هذا رصدناه
ايضا يوم امس كان هناك استهداف وقصف عنيف
سواء كان من قوات المدفعيه او من الدبابات
المحتشد على تخوم قطاع غزه ولكن ايضا
بالقصف المدفعي الذي يكاد لا يتوقف على
هذه المناطق في بيانه الصباحي قال المتحدث
العسكري الاسرائيلي بانه خلال ال 24 ساعه
الماضيه تم قصف ما لا يقل عن 100 هد
وهو يصف هذه الاهداف بانها منشات ومقرات
قياده تابعه لحركه حماس
ولحركة تحديدا في منطقه خان يونس وهي
المناطق التي يركز كما يقول الناطق
العسكري الاسرائيلي الجيش مجهوده الحربي
في تلك المناطق ما زالت بطيئه وتستغرق
وقتا طويلا وفقا لتصريحات الناطق العسكري
الاسرائيلي دانييل غاري ووفقا ايضا للرئيس
هيئه اركان الجيش هيرتي هاليفي فانها قد
تستغرق وقتا وسيكون هناك فرق في الانتقال
الى المراحل التاليه في هذه الحرب من
القتال الواسع وعمليات القصف المكثفه فيما
يتعلق بالمناطق الشماليه ومناطق الجنوب اي
انه اي انه عمليا الجيش يعتبر نفسه بانه
انتقل في المناطق الشماليه الى المرحله
التاليه من الحرب المرحله الثالثه وهي
عمليات محدوده اكثر واقل عمليات قصف لكن
كما تسمعون مناطق الوسط
والمناطق الجنوبيه ما زالت في هذه المرحله
من القصف الواسع وعمليات استهداف واسعه
وعمليات قتال الكبيره ايه وسيله هذا اليوم
تحدثت صحيفه دعوت احرونوت عن تقرير في
غايه من الاهميه وهو بانه رغم الاعداد
التي يعلنها الجيش الاسرائيلي عن الاصابات
بين الجنود وهو يتحدث عن مجمل اصابات منذ
بدايه الحرب ب
200300 جندي مصاب تقريبا الا ان الكاتب
يقول بان المختصين ومن يقدمون العلاج
للمصابين يتحدثون عن صوره قاتمه اكثر
بكثير ومن بينهم يذكر المستشفيات وقسم
اعاده تاهيل الجنود في وزاره الدفاع
واطباء م ميدانيين يعملون في الجيش الى
جانب ال الجنود بالاضافه الى ايه قسم
معاقي ال الجيش الاسرائيلي وهذه منظمه بحد
ذاتها يتحدثون عن اعداد اكبر بكثير ممن
اصيبوا اصابات ادت الى اعاقات مستدامه لدي
اد
العام
الى و500 جندي مصابا
باعقيل كمعاق في الجيش وهذا يترتب عليه
دفع تعويضات وميزانيات هائله لهم وسيله
وهذه الارقام بالتاكيد تزعج
وتقلق الجانب الاسرائيلي الرسمي الى جانب
الاخبار عن الخلافات في الشق السياسي
والامني ما التفاصيل نجوان التي تكشفت عن
فشل الاجتماع الامني المصغر وخلافات
اعضائه هذا الموضوع يستحوذ على كافه
النقاشات صباح هذا اليوم في وسائل الاعلام
وبين الخبراء والمختصين توصف باسرائيل هذه
الخلافات وما تسرب عن ال مشادات ال
الشديده كما وصفت في المجلس الوزاري الامن
المصغر الليله الماضيه بانها فضيحه وبانها
و وصمه عار
وبانها يعني حدث كبير في ان يحدث في خلال
حرب تخوضها اسرائيل هذه الخلافات بدات
الليله الماضيه بهجوم وفقا لما تسرب من
قبل ال الوزير اتمار بن كبر وزير الامن
القومي ووزير الماليه بيتسل ايس موتش من
الاحزاب الدينيه
الصهيونيه بهجوم على رئيس هيئه اركان
الجيش الاسرائيلي لا سما او بسبب تحديدا
وفقا لما اعلن ايه تعيينه للجنه تحقيق
ستبدا بالتحقيق فيما يسمى الاخفاق الكبير
العسكري والاستخباراتي والامني في السابع
من اكتوبر هذا التحقيق سيتعلق بالعمل
العسكري وبفشل الجيش الاسرائيلي بالتصدي
لهذا الهجوم وايضا تحقيقات تتعلق بسير
العمليه ال العمليات العسكريه والحرب على
غزه يشمل ذلك ايضا التحضر للعمليه البريه
لكن هذا لا يروق
للجناح الاكثر تطرفا في هذه الحكومه بين
كفير اتهم هيرسي هاليفي بانه اختار شخصيات
ومنها وزير الامن وزير الدفاع السابق
ورئيس هيئه اركان الجيش السابق شاؤول مفاز
بانه هو من كان وزيرا للدفاع في زمن
اي تنفيذ خطه الانفصال عن غزه عام 2005
وهو طبعا ما ما عرضه ويعارضه المستوطنون
وايضا بن كفير الذي الذي يمثلهم وبالتالي
يقول بان حتى هذه اللجنه التي عينها
اي هيرتي هاليفي يجب ان يحقق معها وليس هي
من يجب ان تحقق في احداث السابع من اكتوبر
بالنظر لكونها شريكه في خطه الانفصال عن
غزه والانسحاب من المستوطنات في عام 2005
وكذلك سموتريتش كانت لديه اتهامات كبيره
لرئيس هيئه اركان الجيش خلال هذه الجلسه
هذا لا يروق بطبيعه الحال للمؤسسه الامنيه
والعسكريه في اسرائيل ولذلك هناك ضجه
كبيره لا سما وانه تسرب عن بنيامين
نتنياهو وفقا للوصف في وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه بانه كان مستمتعا بهذه
المشدات بين الجانبين بين بين كفير وسموت
وايضا اثنين من وزراء حزب لكود ميري ريجف
و دودي بن بن سالم وبالتالي من الواضح
هناك يعني من من يتحدث عن ان نتنياهو هو
من يدفع باتجاه هذه الخلافات ويشجع وزراء
من حزبه ووزراء في الصهيونيه الدينيه
لمهاجمه رئيس هيئه اركان الجيش لانه منذ
بدايه هذه الحرب حاول ان يلقي بالمسؤوليه
بمسؤوليه الاخفاقات الامنيه والاستخبارات
والسياسيه والعسكريه ايضا فيما حدث في
السابع من اكتوبر على كاهل المؤسسه
العسكريه وكان قد اشار في تغريدات سابقه
ومنشورات سابقه اجبر لاحقا على حذفها بان
المسؤوليه تقع على رئيس هيئه الاركان على
الجيش على الاستخبارات العسكريه وليس على
الحكومه لتبرئه نفسه من كل ما يحدث وسيله
شكرا جزيلا لك نجوان سمري مراسلتنا من
غلاف
غزه